- Ça va?
- Cindy travaille dans
une ressource intermédiaire
du réseau de la santé. Elle a eu
la COVID il y a quelque mois.
Pour l'instant, elle n'est pas
vaccinée.
CINDY SYRIAQUE, agente relations
humaines des services sociaux
- De base, je ne suis pas
la personne qui est anti-vaccin.
Ce qui me dérange beaucoup,
avec celui-ci, c'est le manque
de recul que je considère qui
est... qui manque vis-à-vis,
admettons, les effets à court,
moyen, long terme. Mais moi,
malgré ça, j'ai quelque chose
en dedans de moi qui me dit :
Tu sais quoi? You know what?
Si je peux attendre de voir
ce qu'ils vont encore sortir
comme faits scientifiques
sur le vaccin, je préfère
attendre.
- Même si les données
indiquent que les vaccins sont
sécuritaires et qu'ils ont été
approuvés par Santé Canada,
elle se sent déchirée.
- Je suis très déchirée entre
suivre la voix en dedans
de moi, suivre mes valeurs,
mes convictions, versus
le travail que j'aime faire.
Fait que... Des fois, je me dis
: Bon, juste, prends-la,
ta dose, puis tu vivras
avec les conséquences après
s'il y en a, mais je me connais,
je vais angoisser pareil après.
- Et Cindy Syriaque n'est pas
la seule : 22 000 travailleurs
de la santé ne sont pas
vaccinés. La mise en place
d'une nouvelle date butoir
pour convaincre les hésitants
est-elle la voie à suivre?
La Dre Cécile Rousseau a dirigé
l'élaboration d'un guide pour
mieux comprendre l'hésitation
vaccinale, une réalité qui
existe depuis l'apparition
des vaccins.
Dre CÉCILE ROUSSEAU, professeure
à l'Université McGill
- L'obligation vaccinale marche
pour augmenter la couverture
vaccinale, mais attention,
ce n'est pas la méthode
recommandée habituellement
pour s'adresser à l'hésitation
vaccinale. Parce que leur
confiance dans l'institution
de santé, leur confiance dans
la société en général serait
meilleure si on les accompagne
dans une décision et qu'on
respecte leur décision
que si on les force.
- Quand je lui ai dis ça...
- Dans le cas de Cindy,
à ce point-ci, le report
de la date limite au 15 novembre
ne change pas sa position.
- Oui, le 15, on est
sans salaire.
(silence)
C'est grave, là!
- Je pense que face au passeport
vaccinal, à l'obligation
vaccinale, on a probablement
atteint la limite du noyau dur
de ceux qui ne veulent pas
se faire vacciner.
- Est-ce que tu regardes
ailleurs pour voir quel autre
emploi tu pourrais occuper,
ou t'es pas encore rendue là?
- C'est sûr que je regarde
ailleurs, mais en toute
franchise, c'est comme...
au fond de moi, est-ce que
je veux vraiment aller ailleurs?
La réponse, c'est non.
- Ici Mélissa François,
Radio-Canada,